- Hello, and welcome everybody.
Thank you all for joining
us, thank you for coming,
and welcome to How It's
Made, the RITM book edition,
an event in which we'll celebrate
and hear from three Yale faculty members
who have authored important
books in recent months.
I'm Steven Petty, director of Yale Center
for the Study of Race, Indigeneity,
and Transnational Migration,
and professor of History, American Studies
and Ethnicity, Race, and Migration.
I'm gonna be moderating
today's conversation
which should run a little
longer than an hour.
Since its founding in 2016,
the RTTM Center has worked
to support publications
by students and faculty
and to organize events of
interest on the Yale campus
and other academic settings
and for wider groups of
people who aren't affiliated
with a college or a university.
So I hope that you'll keep
your eyes open for news
of other events and opportunities
through our RITM in the
days and weeks to come.
If you aren't already receiving
our weekly newsletter,
please sign up for it today.
The link will be posted soon in the chat.
I'm gonna introduce
briefly our three speakers
in the order in which
there'll be discussing
their books today.
Each of them will talk
for five to 10 minutes,
and then we'll open
the floor to questions.
So if you have a question for
one or more of our authors,
please post it in the Q&A.
We are very eager to hear from you,
and I know that our authors
would love to respond
to any questions that you have.
Our first speaker today
is Laura Barraclough,
the Sarai Ribicoff Associate Professor
of American Studies at Yale.
Laura is an interdisciplinary
scholar of land,
memory, identity, and
inequality in the United States.
She's the author of Making
the San Fernando Valley:
Rural Landscapes, Urban
Development , and White Privilege,
and she's co-author with
Laura Pulido and Wendy Cheng
of A People's Guide to Los Angeles.
She will be speaking
today about her new book,
Charros: How Mexican
Cowboys are Remapping Race
and American Identity,
published by the University
of California press.
Daniel Martinez HoSang
is an Associate Professor
of Ethnicity, Race and
Migration in American Studies
with a secondary appointment
in the Department of Political
Science at Yale University.
Dan's work explores US
political culture in many sites,
including electoral,
politics, social movements,
and cultural formations.
He is the author of Racial Propositions:
Ballot Initiatives and the
Making of Postwar California,
and the co-editor of three
books, including one entitled,
Seeing Race Again:
Countering Colorblindness
Across the Disciplines.
Dan will be speaking today
about his recent book,
Producers, Parasites, Patriots:
Race, and the New Right
Wing politics of Precarity,
which he co-authored with Joseph Lowndes
and which was published
by the University of Minnesota press.
Our third speaker today
is Ana Ramos-Zayas,
a professor of Ethnicity,
Race and Migration,
and of American Studies and
Anthropology at Yale University.
Ana is the author of
National Performances:
Class, Race and Space
in Puerto Rican Chicago,
and of Street Therapists: Affect, Race
and Neoliberal Personhood
in Latino Newark.
She is also coauthor of Latino Crossings,
Mexicans, Puerto Ricans and the Politics
of Race and Citizenship,
and she has two co-edited
books that are forthcoming,
(speaking in foreign language)
and Latino-Latina Studies,
and Whiteness in Latin
America and the Caribbean.
Ana will be speaking today
about her recent book,
entitled, Parenting
Empires: Class Whiteness,
and the Moral Economy of
Privilege in Latin America,
which was recently published
by Duke University Press.
And with that, I'm gonna
turn this over to Laura
and just ask Laura to talk a little bit
about the making of her book,
Charros: How Mexican
Cowboys are Remapping Race
and American Identity.
Laura?
- Thank you so much, Steve,
and thanks to my colleagues,
Dan and Ana, for being here.
This idea has been a
long time in the making,
and given COVID, given
the state of the world,
it took us a while to be together,
but I'm so happy to be here
and to be in celebration,
and thank you all for coming.
I'm gonna try to share my slides here.
One moment, please.
Okay, I'm speaking today,
as Steve mentioned,
from my new book, Charros:
How Mexican Cowboys
are Remapping Race and American Identity.
And in a general sense,
the book is really
tracking the various ways
in which Mexican immigrant and
Mexican-American communities
in the United States have mobilized
to this extremely significant figure
of the charro pursuit of
various political, social,
and cultural initiatives
in the United States.
And so I just wanna briefly explain
what a charro is or who a charro is.
He is probably most familiar
to two folks because the charro suit,
or the (speaking in foreign language),
is worn by mariachi musicians.
But the charro that I am writing about
in the book is related more to
the acts of horseback riding,
and so, and branching,
and roping, and rodeo.
So the best translation
of the word, charro,
might be Mexican horseman and, you know,
just an aside, that as the
publisher and I were deciding
on the title for the book,
in the subtitle is, Mexican Cowboys.
And I think that's a partial translation
but it's not a great translation because
at least in the US the
image we have of a cowboy
is of a kind of a working
class, isolated, rough figure,
and in Mexico the figure of the charro
is much more associated with the elite,
with landowners, and with most of all,
probably most significantly,
with highly skilled
dignified work on horses
with other ranch owners.
So it's much more of an
elite or a gentleman,
the gentlemen horseman might
be a better translation.
And charros have a long history
in Mexico, 400-plus years.
It's a figure that's associated
with Spanish colonization
and he really has contested
divergent meanings.
So on the one hand, he has been associated
with the elite in Mexico,
the Spanish colonial elite,
but he also has been associated
with nationalist revolutionary figures,
like Emiliano Zapata and Pancho Villa.
And so part of what I was interested in
are those struggles over
what the charro should mean
in terms of its class status
and his relationship
to Mexican nationalism.
But the particular contribution of my book
was to try to track the
ways that those debates
had been carried out in the United States.
So the charro is very, very
well-studied within Mexico.
There's great critical
scholarship by Mexican scholars,
a lot of which I cite in the book,
but he had not been the study
of significant scholarship in the US,
and this is despite the fact that charros
have emerged as political
actors in the United States
as early as the 1930s
we did have a couple of good ethnographies
by anthropologists that had
been conducted in the 1990s
but there was really no history
of the ways that charros had been used
by Mexican-American communities.
And so that was the purpose of my book,
how Mexican communities
in the US have mobilized
this complicated and yet
very significant figure
for a variety of social and
political change initiatives.
Importantly, my book
was not an ethnography.
It is an analysis that is
very much public facing.
I was focused on how
ethnic Mexican communities
have tried to impact
various public institutions
and social structures and to
link that to the long history
of dispossession and racialization
in the United States.
And sometimes that involved looking
at how charro communities in the US
had challenged whitewashed mythologies
of ranching and rodeo and
cowboys in the Americas.
And so that is where the
idea of the subtitle,
how these cowboys,
again, an inadequate term
have remapped American identity in part
by invoking this longer
and hemispheric history
of the charro in the US.
So I used a variety of sources,
Spanish and English language newspapers,
lots of archival collections deposited
in various US institutions,
mostly in the Southwest
by middle-class Mexican-American figures
who were involved with
general associations
or associations of men
who ride and rope together
and compete together.
A few interviews, looking
at legislative documents,
school curricula, all kinds of things.
It's a very interdisciplinary study.
And a lot of this was about place,
which we'll talk a
little bit about later on
in our conversation.
And so I just want to show you some
of the specific case studies
that the book is looking at.
I started in Los Angeles where the focus
was really on the ways that the
charro will became a vehicle
for Mexican-Americans
to integrate the state,
and specifically the Los
Angeles Sheriff's Department.
This is Sheriff Eugene Biscailuz,
who could trace his identity back
to elite California families
and who dressed up as a charro
as the head of the Los
Angeles Sheriff's Department.
There was also a group of
working class Mexican-Americans
from East LA who joined the
Sheriff's posse in this period.
And this is in the 1940s and 1950s,
and I think this is a
really important counterpart
to other studies of Mexican-Americans
in LA in the war time era
who were mostly persecuted by the police.
But in this case, charros were
also members of the police.
And you can see that here.
These are LA Sheriff's
Department posse charros
in the background of this photo.
I also have a study of
San Antonio in the 1940s
and '50s where the charros
were much more focused
on the economy.
So these were folks who were
part of the city's tiny,
tiny middle-class,
Mexican-American middle-class
but who were uniquely positioned to draw
on the image and the history
of the charro to build a
binational tourist economy,
drawing in investors from Northern Mexico
at a time when San
Antonio was really trying
to propel its own urban growth.
And so that gave them a
degree of economic leverage.
I also have some materials on Colorado,
and in my chapters on
Denver and Pueblo, Colorado,
I really am drawn to this
person, Lena Archuleta,
who was the first Hispana principal
of Denver Public Schools and
who was centrally involved
in the work towards desegregation,
bilingual education,
and culturally responsive
curriculum in part
by offering a curriculum
guide called The Rodeo,
I'm sorry, it's blocked by my screen,
but It's Rich Spanish-Mexican Heritage.
And so for her, in Denver,
the work of the charro,
she was a charro, or a charra,
this really influential local principal,
and again, drew on the charro as a source
of empowerment for
Spanish-speaking children.
I also look at the ways that Charreria,
or Mexican rodeo could be
used to help ethnic Mexicans
claim public space as they were
suburbanizing in Los Angeles
and to a lesser extent suburbs
of other Southwestern cities.
And here, my hope was to
show how suburbanization
and residential integration is
not only about private space
but about struggles for public space
and the expression of a cultural
identity as a way, again,
of transforming racialized structures.
And I finish the book
By looking at the ways
that charros have been caught up
in animal welfare legislation.
Several of the events in the Mexican rodeo
have been deeply contested
and controversial,
and they've been subject
to a lot of critique
by animal rights activists,
which has forced them into
the legislative sphere.
And so my last chapter looks
at the ways that those
debates about animal welfare
have have really led
charros to scale up away
from the local level and become
national political actors,
regional and national political actors
in a way that they become
formal political subjects.
I'm going to just close
by saying something
about how I came to this project,
and I'll stop my screen
share for a second.
So I came to this
project because I grew up
in the suburbs of Los Angeles
in the 1980s and 1990s.
And this was a time, as
Dan has written about
in his first book, Racial Propositions,
that was deeply, deeply
contentious around issues
of race and immigration.
The way that I experienced
those was that I grew up
in a protected rural neighborhood
in the city of Los Angeles
where horse-keeping
was protected, where the
rights to keep chickens
and other farm animals was
protected by city government,
and it was also as a
neighborhood that was something
like 90% white at a time when the city
of LA was becoming a majority Latinx,
like less than 30% white
at the county level.
And so I became very
interested in the relationships
between the city's protection
of rural landscapes
and the unbelievably
disproportionate whiteness
of that neighborhood.
And so I wrote about
that in my first book,
Making the San Fernando Valley.
But it was also clear
even in those moments that
that was never the whole story.
And in fact, for this book,
I was really drawing on my own experiences
as a child growing up riding
around my neighborhood
and meeting out in public
space charros who were
riding their horses pride
fully with dignity, with skill.
And I also, so I was able
to see that in public space
in my neighborhood, my
majority white neighborhood,
but these were folks from
adjacent neighborhoods.
But also I was able to see how
threatened local white folks
in my neighborhood were by
those alternative histories
of of horsemanship and skill.
And so this book was really
about trying to untangle
those relationships and those tensions.
And I'll just say as a way of wrapping up
it has been amazing to me to realize
that I have spent the last 15 years
of my life and at least two books
and some articles basically
trying to figure out
the tensions and the
contradictions of my childhood.
And I think that's one of the things
that ethnic studies
scholarship and scholarship
in general can allow us to do.
So thank you very much.
I'll pass it over to Dan.
- Thanks so much, Laura.
I so appreciate like in your work,
just how rigorous the balance is
between like history and place-based,
then it moves across all these sites,
and how you've just
narrated its connection
to your own experiences.
So just again, thanks to Steve and RITM
and folks who are listening today.
And I'll just say, you know,
in terms of like methodology
for especially students
listening, if you're looking
for good models and examples,
please follow Laura and Ana.
Because the only methodology
that I can share here
is kind of looking at things politically
that have taken place in the
last 10 years that relate
to the kind of bottom dropping out,
it seems, of our social life and economy
and fabric and the ways
they've intersected
with these kind of unusual
developments connected
to racial politics.
So I just thought to try to share some
of like how that works for us.
I would just share some of these images
and kind of talk about what for us
are always just questions
on top of questions,
on top of questions.
So this is the book, Producers,
Parasites, and Patriots,
and before I was at Yale,
I was at the University
of Oregon for 10 years.
So that's really where
this took root in 2012
right after the midterm elections.
My co-author Joe Lowndes
and I tried to figure out
some of these developments.
And I'll just start with
this since this group,
the Proud Boys, was mentioned for those
that might've watched the
presidential debates last night.
So a group that was started
in 2016 by Gavin McInnes,
co-founder of VICE Magazine and Media
which kind of represented itself as a,
what they call as a Western
chauvinist organization.
So they certainly would disavow
that they were white supremacists as such,
and yet constantly
involved in not just kind
of like street level
violence and fighting,
but actually they became the
kind of like street force
of Trumpism in the
aftermath of the election.
And you'll see here, these are photos
from different Proud Boys gatherings.
And you know what startling here
is the three-fingered Okay symbol,
which is now generally
taken up to be a symbol
of white supremacy offered
up by not just, you know,
a man of who color seemed to
like wandered into the photo,
but men of color who seem much
more central to this project.
And so part of what we know is,
this is not all of the book but, you know,
part of the book was
thinking about what we call
the kind of multiracial
or multicultural far-right
that has emerged since
2016, that goes hand in hand
with the most white supremacist tendencies
of the Trump administration
and of conservatism today.
And yet, you know, from our perspective,
didn't have good accounts
to think about kind
of how this was happening
or where this came from.
So in the lower left corner,
this is a photo of the
Proud Boys in New York City.
You'll see a photo on the right,
or image of not only just
all these men of color,
but actually like self-described
Guatemalan skinheads,
immigrant skinheads engaged
in immigrant bashing
in New York City.
So again, a lot for us
to get our heads around,
and I'll talk a little bit
more about where we ended up.
But these are some of
what we kind of took up.
I would say, you know, during the book,
we didn't conduct too many interviews,
but you know, really the
most kind of vexing moment
was when we talked to
this figure in the middle
of Joey Gibson, who at
the time was running for,
he was a kind of outsider candidate
for a Republican Senate seat in Washington
and had just founded a
group called Patriot Prayer
which has been very, very active
in these kinds of street
brawls in Portland.
And we asked him like, well,
where do your politics come from?
Like who's influenced you?
And Gibson went on this long
and very serious and
sincere account of Dr. King,
of the Greensboro lunch counter sit-ins
and their capacity to
withstand state violence
and their willingness to challenge it.
He talked about the tragedy
of the war on drugs,
and again, how the state has reached in
and disrupted the lives
of so many black families
and communities.
You had a critique of big pharma.
And so this was a strange, you know,
we left the interview like,
is this just kind of mouthing,
you know, if you were a progressive
and self-identified kind of anti-racist,
these would be predictable
kind of significations.
But for Gibson, he was
really in this active process
of thinking about how certain traditions
of the Civil Rights movement
might be incorporated
into what was a very
grassroots far-right project.
So these are some of the
topics we take up in the book,
especially in the latter chapters,
about the kind of
multiculturalism of the far-right.
We write about this figure
on the right, Sonnie Johnson,
who was a close confidant
of Andrew Breitbart
at Breitbart Media, very
close to Steve Bannon,
a movement builder within
very conservative circles.
Has her own weekly radio
show on Breitbart Radio
that one can listen to if you
have Sirius Satellite Radio
that I highly, highly recommend.
She's really an anti-racist
figure on the right
who has a vision of that the far-right
might be cleansed of the
kind of racial antagonisms
that's been associated
with in the last 40 years,
in particular, and that
essentially black communities
could be the heart of a new pro-business,
militarized kind of anti-choice,
anti-feminist right-wing project
in which black people
would be the exemplars
of those commitments.
But there are just some
other examples images.
So, you know, these
groups would often like go
to kind of typical liberal setting,
in this case, Evergreen State University.
And you can see, you know,
these openly Islamophobic and violent,
it says United States ISIS Hunting Permit,
and then this kind of provocation.
Yeah, we're a racist group
that accepts accepts members
of all races.
But in fact, that's
precisely what they are.
They are a racist group on the far-right
that is multi-racial in some ways.
You know, it reminds us that it's not,
the critique is not just,
well, if the Klan had
a diversity initiative
and were more inclusive,
then they would be, you know,
kind of like politically there.
It's also the substance
of what they talk about
and that they're dynamic in this way.
This is Enrique Tarrio,
Afro-Cuban based in Miami,
who's the head, the nominal
head of the Proud Boys now.
This is a picture with
him and Roger Stone again
showing a white power sign.
So how are these sutures
and these connections
being made in kind of realtime?
Just a couple more images.
This is Diamond and Silk,
who often have appeared on
the campaign trail with Trump,
helping shore up his kind
of nativist commitment,
suggesting, and this certainly
has no correspondence
to actual political behavior,
but this argument that,
you know, they have this line,
Clinton could do mass incarceration,
we can do mass deportation.
So a very kind of tricky, again,
kind of suturings that are happening.
And, you know, another like,
Whoa, what is going on?
This is Paul Nehlen who ran
for a GOP seat in Wisconsin,
and he was a pretty
unapologetic white supremacist.
He was like, you know, they
discovered these connections
he had and he kind of admitted them.
He had Diamond and Silk
do a commercial for him,
which, you know, he used to try to talk
about protecting American jobs.
His rabid all white base
loved the appearance
of Diamond and Silk, partly, you know,
because it deflected perhaps
charges their own racial animus
but much more because
from their perspective,
they really animated this
vision of a US nationalist,
militarized nativist formation
that could be multiracial.
And I don't want to say,
this is not targeted in any
way towards black voters.
This is for a white
voters on the far-right?
This is Steve Bannon who we found actually
was continually making
these appeals and addresses
to black businessmen and
conservatives in particular
about how once the kind of era
of globalism and US support
for neo-liberalism ended,
hundreds of billions
of dollars could be invested
into black communities
and the traction he got in that claim.
And that while we're
more familiar, you know,
people have seen Kanye or Candace Owens,
who's actually a much
different kind of figure,
there is a small, but
potent bench of black
and Latinx conservatives
in particular who really
have a vision for how a new
Republican party might be built
in the wake of this and who are as far
to the right as Trump.
This is Senator Tim Scott,
beloved by white Tea Party
members in South Carolina,
far more than someone like Lindsey Graham.
Mia Love. a Republican
Congresswoman for four years.
This is her speaking at a gun rights rally
in Salt Lake City.
You can see Confederate flags
and militia flags there.
You know, I just want to share this image.
It's a little distorted, but
this is from a web graphic.
It says, "Which is the
party of responsibility?"
Republican, it shows Love.
By age 30, married, two kids,
Saratoga Springs Council.
This is Sandra Fluke, who
the Democrats had asked
to testify around access to birth control.
And so in this vision,
Love is the producer,
the good proper patriotic subject,
and Fluke is the irresponsible kind
of feminist subject who needs discipline.
So these are just configurations
we would not have expected.
I'll just end here.
This is Kay Coles James.
She's now president, a black woman,
of the Heritage Foundation,
really the conservative kind
of like compass on the right.
It continues to be as
conservative as you would imagine,
all-white, as you can see in this photo,
but led by a long time kind
of conservative movement builder.
So I'll just wrap up to say,
because I felt like I
wanted to say something
by way of like implications here,
that the incorporation of people of color
on the right actually and paradoxically
makes white supremacy more durable.
It shores up and legitimates
its core features
of militarism, patriarchy,
nationalism, and hierarchy,
the inevitability of hierarchy.
These incorporations are
really quite central,
surprisingly, to Trumpism,
and they can exist
with Trump's more open
white nationalist appeals
and they are not
collapsing under the weight
of their own contradictions.
And as we think, regardless of
what happens in the election,
all the kinds of
reconstructions and things
that will happen, this is
something that's not going away.
And I'll just end because we do talk
about a lot of the grassroots organizing
that's happening on the
other side to re-imagine
and rebuild social relations
that could contest this,
particularly, in rural
areas, this wonderful group
the Rural Organizing Project.
Okay, so that's just a snapshot,
and as chaotic and frenzied as I sound,
that's partly our methodology in the book.
And I'm going to turn it over to you
so they can hear about a
proper academic project.
- I don't know if a
proper academic project,
but he's been wonderful to
hear both Laura and Dan's work.
Oftentimes even though we
share meetings and all of that,
we have very little time to really share
our respective academic projects.
So this is really a treat.
So my book is really almost
like an outlier in terms
of my broader work that
I've done throughout
(speaking faintly)
Most of the time, in
most of the other work,
I focused on working
class Latinx communities
in Chicago and in Newark.
And that has been really the center
of the work that I started doing as part
of my graduate dissertation,
my doctoral dissertation,
and all the way until about 2012
when I decided to explore
the other side of inequality
and started to try to understand not only
how inequality damages
the possibilities of some,
but also how it actually benefits others.
And to do that, I decided
to do an ethnography
that involved participant
observation, interviews,
and lots of different methodologies
including some archival work.
And it is a comparative ethnography
of two neighborhoods,
two elite wealthy mostly
white neighborhoods.
One of them is Ipanema, in Rio de Janeiro,
and the other one is El
Condado, in Puerto Rico.
I spent about a month in each place
and my friends were really
joking with me about it.
They were like, Oh, wow, you
went from walking the streets
of Newark to like really
hanging out at the beaches
of the Caribbean and the
Atlantic coast of South America.
And the truth was that a
lot of times anthropologists
and ethnographers are associated
with deep hanging out,
what we call it deep hanging out.
So part of the research
that you do really involves
trying to not only interview people,
but see if what they
do in practice actually
supports what they tell you that they do.
So that's part of why we spend
so much time with people.
One of the things that I wanted to,
the reason why I chose,
there were several reasons why I chose
these two specific sites,
but what I found interesting
since we're talking
about the actual, you know,
the background of bookmaking,
is that I got quite a bit of pushback
for assuming Puerto Rico to
be part of the Latin-American
and Caribbean geography rather
than being part of the US.
There was a very strong push
for me to turn this book
into a US/Brazil comparison,
even if I did go to Puerto Rico,
and I had to really
push back against that,
and I felt very strongly
that I just wanted
to remove Puerto Rico for from
the side of exceptionalism
where it's neither cover by
American Studies oftentimes
or by Latin American studies because both
of them feel that it doesn't
fit quite into either one.
So mostly I did my work
among very wealthy parents.
And the reason why I chose
parenting was because
I really wanted to study not
people's necessarily income
or economic wealth in a
traditional Marxist sense,
but also in terms of how
they made the decisions,
our money and our own resources moral?
How do they explain that they
have so much more than others?
It was a really challenging
project because I really,
all the time I was trying not to judge,
which is part of what we try to, you know,
in anthropology, we try
to sort of step back
and let people be who they
are and sort of analyze
what we get there, although
that's not always possible.
So one of the things that
I did, that I found out
was also a contradiction.
Like when Dan was talking,
it made me realize that it was
really a big contradiction.
I mean, here we have very wealthy parents
who are very anti-consumption.
They really don't want their
kids to have everything.
They're very selective in terms
of what they give to children.
So they're actually not the people
that you would think they are.
They're not, I think I
went in there expecting,
you know, all these very composed,
and people just wearing
all these brand names,
and all these other things.
And in reality, they were not at all.
They were the kind of people
that were very invested
in what I call inner
inner world cultivation,
which means that they
develop their whiteness
as an interiority project.
And so, whiteness for
them is not necessarily
about displaying certain fashion
or certain body practices,
but also about being able to
express who they are as people.
And so, there were several
things that sort of,
that were difficult to put up,
(speaking faintly)
in terms of the actual project
of writing the book and turning
this project into a book.
I think one of the main ones
that happened very later
on in the process was even
the choice of the cover.
So the cover was a back and forth fight
with whoever decides
on covers at the press,
and by the way, I worked
with these Latinx editors,
two of them.
I was like, so blessed with that.
I was just like, really,
they were exceptional.
But you know, when you're
dealing with the presses,
there are a lot of different departments.
And I remember they insisted
that I put a nanny and
a child in the cover.
And for me, I really wanted these to be
about the wealthy parents,
because a lot of times,
what happens in anthropological
work is that we protect,
you know, we protect the wealthy
and very much analyze the
poor and working classes.
So what I wanted was to make sure
that they understood this is not a project
about the nannies.
This is actually a project
about the wealthy people,
and I just wanted the
wealthy people on the cover.
And of course I didn't, I
turned out to be that diva
because everybody, you
know, thinks then like,
Oh my God, she's just like, hey, whatever.
But anyway, so in the
end that worked out and,
you know, that was one of the things that
I kind of pretty much insisted on.
I think one of the main issues
with a project like this,
which is ethnographic,
is that you bring your biography with you.
And of course that's true in every project
to some degree or another.
And in this particular case,
it was really a tough
project to be part of,
not for the reason, you
know, it was tough because,
obviously the entrance
piece of like trying
to get in touch with people
that are this wealthy,
the wealthy are very protected.
So how do you get in touch with them?
Once that is obtained, once that happens,
one of the things that
becomes really difficult
is to try to learn to be at
ease with this particular crowd
that you are working with and, you know,
that are your interlocutors.
And so that those are parts of the project
that I worked throughout.
Of course, you know, I was very aware
of where the nodules of privilege were
in the El Condado side since
I grew up in Puerto Rico,
and I grew up in not in
any of those circles,
but I knew all of them.
Like, you know, everybody kind of knew
where the good schools were and
where the country clubs were
and all of that.
And then in Brazil, the
challenges actually were different
because I was very accepted as somebody
who was not from there,
so everybody wanted
to show me their lives.
But at the same time,
it was also this kind
of consistently trying
to understand people
for who they were in their context
that they were, you know,
where they were showing me,
and at the same time, develop
an analytical take on them,
on the project.
So I see both of the, a lot
of people have asked me,
you know, why Brazil
is such a big country,
Puerto Rico is such a small country,
like all these other things.
And I explained, in the
book I spent quite some time
explaining why I feel that these units,
the neighborhood units are comparable.
I don't know how to share my PowerPoint
but let me see if I can just, Oh, okay,
actually that's pretty, yeah,
so I'm not going to share
very many of the slides.
I just want to show
the cover that I chose.
But I also want to show the similarities
of the two neighborhoods
that I focused on.
So on the left, there
is, I wish I could point,
but so on the left is El Condado.
As you can see, there
is a lagoon where a lot
of the wealthy people
spend their time kayaking,
doing water sports, all of that.
At the other side is the
Atlantic ocean and the beach,
and that also created some luxury culture
that was very much
present among these elites
and in their parenting.
Ipanema on the right, if
you look at both places
from the top, there's
quite a bit of similarities
in the landscape of each.
And one of the things that
I center on is how does
the geographies, particular
geography that has become
associated with wellness
and healthy living
and fitness and all these other things
enters the world of parenting?
One thing also that I wanted
to examine through the lens
of parenting was the bigger
question of sovereignty,
and also of the language of corruption.
And so, that became very evident once
I was talking to people.
At this point, both in
Brazil and Puerto Rico,
there were some, you
know, the countries were
in a severe economic crisis,
most people talked about the government
in terms of corruption,
and all of the language became intertwined
with how people view their
way of raising children.
And of course, you know,
when you put children in the,
anything becomes justified,
and that's part of why child,
you know, talking about your children
is particularly powerful
because, you know,
nobody will criticize these wealthy people
for wanting to do, to
protect their children.
So I think that's all that I want to,
that I want to share.
Let me see, I don't know how
I get out of the sharing.
I just do this.
Sorry about that.
So, yeah, so I'm looking forward
to hearing your questions.
- Thank you, Ana, and thank you, Dan,
and thank you, Laura,
for these presentations.
I'm going to remind our audience members,
if you have a question, to
please put them in the Q&A
and we'll do our best to get
to as many of them as we can.
You know, Ana, you shared with us a bit
of the geography of
Ipanema and of El Condado,
and I wanted to take that
question in a sense to Laura
who of course, is a geographer.
And her book, as she mentioned briefly,
covers a lot of territory
and it thinks comparatively
about charros and their
practices in a number
of different places,
California, Texas, Colorado,
as she mentioned, but also
Oklahoma, Kansas, and Nevada,
and perhaps elsewhere.
So Laura, maybe you could
talk a little bit about
how your book uses a comparative
geographical approach,
and you know, what the
challenges of that approach
were for you and the
importance of that approach
were in the writing of this book.
- Thank you.
Yeah, I should say that when
I first started this book
I had no idea where it was
going to go geographically.
I had one story I had stumbled
upon in the archives about a group
of suburban charros in
Los Angeles in the 1970s.
But I didn't know how to,
I didn't know how that was
going to become a book.
It was clear that that story
alone was not the book.
As I started to share the project
and just the general interest
in charros with friends, with colleagues,
with family members,
they started to send
me newspapers articles
or things that they had
found in the archives,
and that led me to places like San Antonio
that I really had very
little knowledge about,
and then sent me to Denver,
and I started just stumbling
across these things.
And it became very clear
to me that the charros
in these various places were not the same.
They were not the same kind
of people in terms of class status.
In some places they were working class,
in some places they were middle-class.
In some places they
were mostly immigrants,
and other places they had
their families had been
in the US, like in New
Mexico since the 1700s.
And so I at first was
really quite overwhelmed
by trying to make sense of this,
how this figure had been used
in so many different ways
by such different groups of people.
I started to wonder how those differences
that I was observing might relate
to the specific geographies
of ethnic Mexican people
in different parts of the US.
And I wanted, I eventually
came to the conclusion
that whatever Charreria and the activism
of charros looked like in different places
was in almost all cases related
to the specific processes
through which ethnic
Mexicans had been subjugated
in those places.
So in San Antonio, it made sense to me,
or it later made sense to me
that the focus was on the economy
because of the violence of
the economy in South Texas
and the fact that ethnic Mexican
people had been so confined
to farm labor, for example.
And so, whereas in Denver,
it took the form of education
for a variety of reasons.
And so for me, that became the project,
was to try to explain
how and why the activism
around the charro looked
so different as a way
to map out the different trajectories
of ethnic Mexican people in various places
across the United States.
And I think this is something
that we see a little bit
in Latinx studies for other figures
like the BRAH-SEHR-ROH
and AH-CHOOK-OH, you know,
that I would like to see more of,
because we know, for
example, LAH-LOH LEE-KOHN
who's at the University of Wisconsin,
did a little bit of work, for example,
on Pachecos in Tucson and
how that was different
in Los Angeles.
I think this is something
that's really important
to think about when we're
studying any racialized community.
The challenge of this was that I did not
have lived experience
in most of these places.
The LA chapters were super easy to, well,
a book chapters never that easy to write,
but they were much easier to write.
The other places, sometimes,
I had never been to
or I'd only been to for a few hours.
And so what I did was I read deeply.
For graduate students on the webinar
or people who have been graduate students,
it felt like I was doing an oral spiel
for each of these places.
You know, I spent a year
reading about Colorado,
ethnic Mexican people in Colorado.
I tried to spend time in
those places whenever I could.
I spent one memorable
day in Pueblo, Colorado,
which was not enough.
Nut it was really important
to get to these places and to feel them,
to feel, and this sounds cheesy,
but to feel what the
land feels like there,
and the spatial arrangements of things,
and to try to understand how
that might've affected the ways that folks
were mobilizing in the past.
And finally, I tried to talk
to people who were from those places.
You know, one day I took the
train down from Yale's campus
to Grand Central Station
and met with Maria Montoya,
a historian, a Western
historian who's now at NYU,
and I just, I was like,
did I get it right,
did I get Colorado right,
and I asked, you know, for
her honest feedback on that.
But I think that was
the hardest part of it,
was trying to learn about
all these different places
and their different
histories of racialization
and subjugation and dispossession,
but also political activism
and to feel, you know,
some degree of confidence in articulating
those different histories.
- Thanks, Laura.
Dan, let me ask you a question that may be
in part about your methodology and it
and it may also address a question
that came in through the Q&A.
You know, you worked on
a collaborative project
that was also a project that
was unfolding in realtime,
and we of course saw this
last night in the debate,
these issues foregrounded centrally
by the current president.
I'd love to hear you talk a little bit
about the methodology that you used
with your co-author and how
you approached this project,
studying things that really
were unfolding around you
even as you were trying
to make sense of them.
- Yeah, thank you,
Steve, for that question.
Just on the collaborative
part, I was working on this
at the same time as
several edited volumes,
and I've just, I'm back to
writing something my own now
and I just found collaborative
writing to be so,
it kind of just opened
up so many possibilities
and I've just thought a
little bit more about why.
And part is there's just
a built-in accountability
when you're writing together
to be constantly engaged with one another.
There's something also about it,
the way it treats writing,
it's always an open-ended practice.
So you can write something, share it,
get feedback, add something.
So the sense that everything you produce
has to be finished and
complete tends to diminish.
And there's just an active
way in which thinking
and writing together when
you're in conversation
just really for me opened
up a writing process.
So we would often do this back and forth
because my coauthor was in
Oregon and I was in Connecticut,
through texts, through other short emails.
But I realized that was
part of the thinking,
these very short efforts
to try to offer a take.
And it just speaks to the second question.
I mean, we were trying
to, at different points,
write about the militia
occupation that was happening
in Eastern Oregon and late 2016,
all of these kind of,
some of the conflicts
that were happening in Portland.
So in that sense, these very
kind of shorter exchanges
in which we were trying to just
get our heads around things
really was a certain kind
of writing methodology.
And the last thing I'll
just say about the chaos is,
I mean, I so appreciate
what Laura is saying
about this effort to get things right,
to feel like you're
accurately representing,
you're spending enough time where you can,
you're not just leaping to a conclusion.
For us, I think we were
relieved of some of that,
because as things were happening,
there were other people writing
in much more comprehensive
and longer-term ways
based on interviews.
We wanted to try to think
about certain kinds of like,
just takes, impressions when we were
putting things together.
So for me, at least I felt a
little free from some of that,
but there would be other scholars
really trying to offer the kind
of definitive archival
account of these episodes,
and we could focus in some ways
on the politics of them
and their implications.
- Great, thank you.
Ana, let me turn to you.
We have a question in the chat
about publishing one's first book
and then publishing a second book
and what you might say to yourself now,
back then when you were
working on your first book,
having since then had some
experience with publishing.
Could you talk about
some of the similarities
and differences between working
on your first pot project
and seeing it through to
publication and working
on this project and seeing
it through to publication?
Yes, that's a great question.
And it makes me reflect
on two moments of my life that
were completely different.
I mean, and I think that the book
and the publication is very much informed
by what predates that process, right,
like where you are in
your life in that moment.
My first book, which was
in Puerto Rican Chicago,
the experience of doing field
work among the activists
in Puerto Rican Chicago changed my life
and shaped who I became as a human being.
That's not the same thing,
and that is reflected in the
kind of writing that I did.
It was very difficult
for me to remain critical
of anything that I was looking at.
I mean, I had like a stronger
sense to please an audience.
I felt that it was very
tough to write that book
from a very emotional perspective,
and I didn't know how books work.
I mean, I was one of these
people that I just like
had no idea what do I do?
So I just started calling presses.
It's like, Oh, well, just call
the University of Chicago,
I'll call it this other one.
And it turned out that, I mean,
one of those lucky moments,
like I called the University of Chicago
and the secretary to the
editor of anthropology
and sociology at the time, David Brent,
just picked up and he's
like, Oh, he's here.
So I just pitched the
thing in two sentences.
He's like, Oh, yeah, and he's like,
Yeah, send me the whole thing.
So that freaked me out.
It's like, Oh my God,
you're not going to ask
for a proposal?
Send me the whole thing.
So the whole thing wasn't ready obviously
because why would it, you know,
I'm just checking and calling.
So I just tried to put it
together and just send it.
I feel that, and that was a
wonderful first experience.
I think it is very rare that
things happen that way now.
This is back in 2000,
I think, around there.
And so for the last book, I felt it was,
my interest in the book was academic
and it was out of certain
curiosity about having become
a mother at the time and
feeling completely overwhelmed,
not by raising a child,
but by the social pressures
of other parents.
So it became being in this hell
of like New York City parenting.
And I said, you know, first, I
need to get out of this hell.
So let's get out of New York and the US
(speaking faintly)
And secondly, you know, I
couldn't just get out of the hell.
I needed to bring my
child with me to the hell
because I can't, you
know, I have a child now.
And so this became something that began
in terms of trying to
understand that reality
and the pressure and the awfulness,
like genuinely becoming an
awful person at moments because
of this role that I was filling
and understanding that
that these role is not
about my own psychological existence.
There is this very,
very structural element
to what parenting looks like
and trying to understand that.
So by the time that I was writing,
that it was coming together,
that I was coming up with the book,
what really sort of was in my head most
is like how much these
parents reassemble my friends,
myself and my friends oftentimes.
And so is coming to terms with that,
with that contradiction of, you know,
I'm critical of these people,
but we are all part of this,
and we are all staying in this.
How do we dismantle it?
Because obviously all this is
doing is enhancing inequality
even if it's unintentional or whatever.
And so for that, I also
got very lucky with this,
but I did have a book proposal ready
just because I needed
to organize my thoughts.
You know, once you come
back from fieldwork,
you have 20 million, you know,
like all these transplant
interviews to transcribe,
fieldwork field notes, you have like tons
and tons and tons of documents and a way
for me to get it together a little bit
was to organize it in
a book proposal format,
and then I just reached out to Duke
because I had liked some
work that they had done
and I touched base with Gisela Fosado,
the Chicana amazing editor,
and it was a joy from then on.
But yeah, but the two were very different.
And I appreciate that question.
- Thanks, Ana.
So you've talked a little
bit about the reception
of your work by editors,
both at Chicago and at Duke.
And Dan, I know you need
to leave a little earlier
than the other panelists,
so I want to ask you a question
about the reception of your work.
You can take this in a direction
that talks about how you
worked with the press,
if you'd like to.
But I actually wanted to
ask you more generally
about how you see the book
on doing work in the world
since its publication,
who you think has read it,
if you've gotten any feedback from it,
who you'd like to see read it,
and what you'd like to see
as the impact of the book.
- Yeah, thank you,
Steve, for that question.
You know, for me, the most
gratifying ways to connect
to readers have been talks
we've been able to give
with some labor unions,
community-based organizations
at other sites which has
involved what, you know,
I think is the rich work
of trying to figure out
the relevance of the
material and its insights
to people's active organizing,
understandings of the
political landscape, et cetera.
So those have been the most satisfying.
I think that more challenging
part, there's been two things.
One is to write a book that
feels like rigorous enough
for our colleagues,
our academic colleagues
that draws on literature,
relevant literature,
while making it accessible
to a wider audience.
And I have to say, that's difficult to do
and something we struggled with,
and I still struggle with.
The other part, I think,
has been like how to not
just turn these into, a lot
of the interviews we did,
they were kind of like, can you talk to us
about these odd characters
and offer some insight
into their psychology,
which was not the point of the book.
And part of what I realized is that,
kind of taken out of context,
that's part of what people can think
that the work was about.
So just kind of like funny people
who have lost their orientation.
So I guess, I'm saying that's, for us,
been part of a balance between, you know,
trying to remain speaks
well to some of what we hope
is like the rigor in the
book and the analysis,
and that it's pushing
while also having it feel
like it's accessible in places
and that it's been easier.
So we're in the same room
talking to people about it,
listening from them,
getting ideas from them,
and that's also been the most
satisfying part of it as well.
- Great, thank you.
Laura, let me ask you then a
version of that same question,
just, you know, how you see
your book working in the world,
if it's had a life since
it was published last year,
if you have any sense about
how it's been received
since it was published.
- I do, thank you for asking.
I think one of the things that
I learned from my first book,
to answer the previous
question that I didn't expect,
but I was able to expect it
the second time around is that,
as authors, you know,
we work on these things
for many years and then we send them out
in the world and there's a
feeling that we are done.
But in fact, that is the first time
that the rest of the world is seeing it,
and so that's actually in
many ways like the beginning
of the book's life, and that
can be difficult actually.
Like I turned this book
in and I was exhausted
and did not want to think
about it for awhile,
and then, you know, the press
requests start rolling in.
So that is something to
think about for those
of you who are publishing your first book,
or really any book.
For me, some of the, I
think of a few things.
One is that I was able
to include photographs
by a really incredible San
Antonio-based photographer,
Al Rendon, as he graciously
gave me permission
to use images on the cover of the book,
and I have in the book,
this photographic interlude,
mostly with photos taken by him,
that tries to just explain
what the different events
are in the charreria.
And for me, one of the things
that was most gratifying
when the book was published
was to see him promote it
on Facebook because of
how meaningful it was
for him as a photographer who had spent
like a decade of his life
photographing these communities.
And so I hadn't really intended that,
but to see the ways that he,
and then I later started to hear
about so many people who
learned about their families
through these, learned
about their communities,
saw their communities in this book,
and that was really gratifying.
As one example which is
probably my favorite story
to share about this, after
I, maybe like six months ago,
I got an email from a Chicano woman
in San Diego who told me
that she found my book
on Amazon because, she's not an academic.
She found my book on Amazon
because she was going to
redecorate her living room
in charro and ranch style decor
and was searching on Amazon for charros,
and there popped up my book.
And she, so that alone is amazing, right,
that people might find our
work when they're not looking
for anything academic.
But she bought it and she read it,
and in the very first
chapter, she saw her father,
she read about her father and her uncle
and some of her neighbors.
And then she wrote to me
and she was like, Oh my God,
you know, like I can't believe it.
And then she sent me
photos that I, you know,
and it was, because I didn't
do a lot of interviews
and I didn't do ethnography for this book,
it was just like to hear that
the book could be useful,
that it could connect with the people
who I was trying to represent
using other kinds of sources was super,
it just made me glad that I had done it,
you know, even though
the book was challenging
in so many ways.
And then one last thing
that I'll add is that
I am now copied on virtually every email
that charros send to their legislators.
You know, I'm in a long list
of BCCs or CCs, you know,
and so I think that they
see me as at least somebody
who is following and
tracking what they do,
which I am.
And it's just been super interesting.
None of those things are
things I would have predicted
and they go well beyond
the academic circles
that I was probably writing for primarily.
- Ana, I know you've you wrote your book
I think it's fair to say
primarily for academic audiences,
but I wonder if you also
had your own interlocutors
in mind as potential readers
and if you could talk about how
you see your book being read
and what kinds of responses
you've received thus far.
- Yes, I'm thinking when
I was listening to Laura,
I'm thinking of my first book that,
the book of Puerto Rican Chicago,
that became a study book
for the very activist
which were part of the book.
So they would meet a book clubs.
I mean, these were very, a
group that was very much aware
of how history mattered in the present.
And so, I think that
was for me very unusual.
I mean, the fact that the very
people who were on the book
are reading it.
And of course, they
could tell who was what,
and that caused all sorts of other things,
even though I had tried to
conceal a lot of, you know?
This current book came out
on the same day that we went
on lockdown in New York.
So all the different
kinds of presentations,
all the different kinds
of things that I wanted
(speaking faintly) to
some people that had been
in the book and all of
that kind of good stuff.
So the most that I've been able to tell
in terms of impact, well, impact
in academic settings, yes,
I mean, I've gotten, you
know, mostly in terms
of visits to pretty much, I
mean, you know, India, UK,
I mean, just like a whole bunch of places,
which surprised me.
But those are academic settings.
But in terms of how
it's actually impacted,
like, I think more of the
people that were in the book
because this is an ethnographic book,
so you know, you always wonder,
and I know that the people
in this book specifically
will read the book.
And one of them has already read the book
and she has been texting me
about wanting to learn more
about her own white privilege,
which is very interesting.
I'm just like, wow.
But, you know, and I told her,
when I go to Puerto Rico,
we can just get together
and talk about this because
right now we're on WhatsApp
and that's like a lot of texting.
You know, but it was
really interesting to hear
her reflection on it and
like what she got out of it.
At that point, she was halfway through,
so I haven't heard from
her since she finished.
I don't know if I said anything
like more objectionable
in the last part of it.
And then actually, another
person from Brazil who works,
you know, who was very
always been very interested
in just experts and stuff like that
also wanted me to give a talk
for one of her organizations.
So there have been initiatives
like that at this point
and all of that has been
sort of colored by COVID.
But yeah, it's always like,
especially for, you know,
for ethnography, it's
just very interesting
to see what their reaction is,
not only for the broader
academic population,
but also for the people that
feel that they're in the book.
So, yeah.
- Great, thank you.
Let me ask all three
of you a final question
and you can take this
in whatever way you want
and tailor it to your own project.
I mean, it strikes me
that for each of you,
the project that you're discussing was,
in some ways, familiar to you in advance
whether it connected
with personal interests
and personal experiences, or in some way,
had relationships to pass
projects that you had done.
But there are other ways in
which each of your projects,
you know, represented
something significantly new.
And, you know, I'm thinking
both for Dan and for Ana,
working with populations, I
think, that you had not worked
in quite this way academically before.
So I'd love to hear all three
of you talk a little bit
about how you oriented
yourself to this new material,
how you thought about your
responsibilities to representing,
the actors and protagonists
and people you were discussing
in this work, and what
you felt to be the kind
of key challenges that you'd
like to share with other people
in taking on a project
that was in some ways new
and in which you may have, you know,
been working with with groups of people
with whom you didn't
share all ways of life
and all ways of thinking.
So, you know, Dan, since again,
I know you're going to need
to take off a little earlier,
maybe we could start with you,
and then go to Ana and
then finished with Laura.
- Sure.
Great, thanks, Steve, for the question.
I mean, you know, I spent a lot,
we spent a lot of time for this project.
We were at militia rallies, you know,
endless hours listening to
right-wing radio on those sites.
And I think what I felt like
I was trying to do there was,
one, really understand
the kind of like logic,
the commitments, the worldview,
listening for the openness to it,
so it's not just that
I already know the kind
of narratives and positions
that people hold and embrace,
and certainly without then
underestimating it's violence,
the potential harm that it had.
You know, the day we
interviewed Joey Gibson,
the next day, he was a
part of a very vicious,
you know, kind of brawl.
So we were on the one hand
trying to offer, you know,
a nuanced account of
the conversation we had
with him while saying
this that's not meant
to minimize everything he's done.
And just the last thing
I'll say is that, you know,
I'm doing a project now on
this right wing radio host,
Sonnie Johnson.
There are long periods of
time when I listen to her
when she's totally criticizing,
lecturing white conservatives
about their racism.
And I strangely identify with her, like,
anti-racist commitments
that she's trying to enact
even though that anti-racism is in service
of a far different vision.
So I actually, I don't
seem to then see all
the connections we can
make as much as just
as these ideas and possibilities
are not somehow like
just the sole possession
of people who I connect
with and identify with.
Those ideas are out there in the world.
They may have come from our communities
and intellectual traditions,
but many, many people
are taking them up, and I think that has
to be taken seriously.
Otherwise, all you do is
just dismiss it and say,
you know, you shouldn't even
be having this conversation.
But that's partly what I've learned here.
- Great, I mean, just listening to that,
you know, it reminds me of
like all this conversation
about cultural appropriation
and to what degree
are these debates becoming
this culturally appropriated,
like appropriated phenomenon.
So I think that's, even though, yes,
these populations were
different from what I've used,
what I've done, the kind of
work that I've done before,
I've always really been interested
in how psychology operates
in a sociological way.
I mean, like how therapy, psychology,
affect even acquire a material life,
and I think that that
continues into this project.
In that sense, it's not super different
from that other kind of project.
What was different, and
it was very helpful,
is to understand how Latinx studies
and Latin-American studies
need to be examine in junction.
They need to be examined together.
I mean, there is so
much wealth of materials
on both sides that will benefit
our reading of the other.
So that actually led to the next,
the edited volume that Steve mentioned,
(speaking faintly)
that I'm doing with my
colleague and friend, Joshua.
So one of the things that I felt
that came out of that process
of the book, you know,
that hadn't come from
previous work was the clarity
of those connections and
those points of convergence
between the fields.
So I would say that
that had been something
that I will continue to think
through and try to implement,
not only in my research,
but also in my teaching
and the classes that I put together.
Because I am very interested
in making sure that,
in classroom discussions,
we have the grasp of a
broader body of literature
even when the grasp is Latinx studies
or Latin American studies.
- For me, this question about how do we,
I hear it partly as how
do we study communities
that we're not fully members of?
And that was a complicated thing for me
that mostly came down to
the methods that I chose
for this book.
So my first book I had
done deep hanging out
of the kind that Ana is talking about.
I wrote about the community
that I grew up in.
I went to four years of really difficult
and painful homeowner's
association meetings.
I was writing about white
folks that I grew up with,
mostly white women and the way
that they thought about land.
And in that sense, that
was a very personal book.
So for the second book, though,
I was writing about people who
lived in nearby neighborhoods
but were men, were older
men, were Mexican-American
or Mexican immigrant.
And so I had to think really
hard, methodologically,
how could I offer something useful?
And it became clear to me pretty quickly
that I could not and did
not want to do ethnography.
And that was hard for
me for a little while
to kind of wrap my head
around because I had been
so committed to ethnography
in the first book.
I think it was also
important to say, you know,
there were logistical things here
that any of us has to think about.
I moved to the east coast.
There are some rodeo and
BUH--KAIR-OH scenes here,
but they're not charros
and it's not the place
that I was trying to write about.
So logistically it became really difficult
for me to imagine doing deep ethnography
with the folks that I was writing about.
But also there had been, and there still
are pretty active animal welfare campaigns
directed at charros and
they are led by people
who look like me, white
women, middle-aged,
who grew up with animals.
And so it was actually
difficult for me to gain access.
And I worry that if I had
chosen to do a different
kind of method, that so
much of the work would
have been charros trying to
convince me to be their ally
and their advocate in
animal welfare debates.
And the two interactions that I did have
that were interviews, longer interviews,
both took that direction really quickly.
And so I had to step back from that
and figure out a different
method that could
still allow me to answer the questions
that I was curious about,
but also that could be
useful to the scholarship.
And so I really thought
about a lot of this book
was writing in service to
and to try to be useful
to my own mentors who were
mostly in Chicano studies,
and to try to do something
that could be useful
to them and to the field.
And it also became about
writing something useful
for the communities that
I was writing about,
but that was not ethnographic.
And again, that was where
I was able to identify
that there was no history
of these communities
in the United States.
There were a few ethnographies.
There was no history and there
was no comparative geography.
And so I landed on that
and I feel okay about that.
Even though it was such a different thing
from my first project it became necessary
because of my own
subjectivity, my own location,
geographically subject
location in relationship
to the folks I was writing about.
And I think the larger
lesson that that taught me
which has become important
as I've matured a bit
as a scholar is to really acknowledge
and embrace the fact that we
can use very different methods
for different projects and
that we can feel differently
about our projects.
The first book was very personal.
The second book was less so,
it was more professional,
or I pursued it for more
sort of professional
and political reasons,
and that in our long lifespan, hopefully,
we get to work on more than one project.
But that there's room for all of that
and that we can do different kinds
of work at different moments in our life,
depending on how we're positioned
and who we're in relationship with.
- Thank you, Laura, and thank
you, Ana, and thank you, Dan.
I think that's a great place to close.
I so appreciate the opportunity to hear
from all three of you about
how your books were made.
And again, for our audience members too,
our audience members,
thank you for coming.
You can see the titles of these books
and some more information
about them in the chat,
if you're interested.
Laura Barraclough's book is
Charros: How Mexican Cowboys
are Remapping Race and American Identity.
Dan HoSang's book is
Producers, Parasites, Patriots:
Race and the new Right-Wing
Politics of Precarity.
And Ana Ramos-Zaya's book
is Parenting Empires:
Class, Whiteness, and the Moral Economy
of Privilege in Latin America.
This has been a great conversation.
I really appreciated hearing
about the contents of the book,
but perhaps more importantly,
how you envisioned
these books and how you
pursued these topics
and how you carried them out,
and how they were ultimately made.
So thank you so much
for being with us today,
panelists and attendees,
and we hope to see you soon
at an RITM event.
Take care.